i asked 13 000 people to rank the
phantom troupe and the results are
pretty wild hello and welcome to the new
world reveal source for everything anime
and manga and today we are here for some
hunter based glory more specifically to
discuss our morally grey group of
protago villains the phantom troupe now
there are lots and lots of videos that
have been made in the past ranking the
phantom troupe including one on this
here very channel thing however those
videos are all essentially the opinion
of one dude in one room whereas what i'm
looking for is the opinion of thousands
of dudes in thousands of rooms so i
opened up a survey in the community
section of the channel asking you all to
rank the troop from your favorite to
least favorite and over 13 000 of you
took up that challenge which is now
going to present us with the definitive
phantom troop ranking but firstly i've
spent quite a bit of time analyzing your
thoughts on fictional criminals so
please do justify my life choices by
subscribing to the new world review
which will also result in consistent
injections of hunter-based culture
administered directly into your youtube
feed and please do say hi in the
comments if you are new to our
association welcome but we are going to
leap straight into the things with
number 15 and sadly that would be last
place which is cortopi i don't think
this was unexpected from anyone however
this does give us a very good chance to
explain how this poll worked sort of
like at a tutorial level you'll notice
that every troop member has received a
final score which is the average of all
of their votes and that's because this
is a ranked choice poll so for example
if i asked you to rank ton per milliki
and beans then the character you put in
first place would receive three points
second place two points and last place
one point then we simply do that roughly
13 000 more times and work out the
average score given per character
however in the case of the phantom troop
we have 15 members to rank so tldr the
closer a troop member score is to 15
then the better they did which makes
scoretopi look quite disappointing
really having a mere scarlet of 2.51 and
i mean for a character who almost never
speaks and is almost never seen and is
certainly in no way relevant i guess it
does make sense and very sadly almost 40
percent of all respondents did decide to
rank cortopia in dead last which is a
proportion that no other troop member
came anywhere near close to achieving
however i would like to give a big shout
out to the exact 27 people out of 13 000
who did rank coretopi surprisingly in
first place the coretopi superfans do
indeed exist there just aren't many of
them sliding into the dms of 14th place
now we discover one franklin bordeaux
with an average score that almost
doubles out of cortopia so the gap
between last and not last is truly
massive very interestingly though only
891 people voted to place franklin in
last place and there are several members
who got significantly more last place
votes than he did however what really
lets franklin down is that over 50 of
all voters placed him somewhere between
11th to 14th and very unfortunately for
franklin not even one percent of
respondents chose him to put him in
first or second so to me that indicates
that franklin is more of a forgotten
troop member not quite memorable enough
to be dumped in last place but just
continuously floating around in a sort
of limbo in the lower end managing to
defeat franklin in 13th position we find
bernoullinov which is our first
fascinating twist of the poll because
around 11 percent of all voters threw
bernoullinov into exactly last place
which is far far far more than franklin
however what makes all the difference is
that bernoullinov really makes a play
for the middle ground he has a string of
absurdly consistent statistics from 7th
all the way to 13th which gives him that
bit of edge over franklin and i suppose
that's because even though we've only
seen him in action once his abilities
are pretty damn amazing because may i
remind you that he conjured the planet
jupiter from his body holes which is
still one of the more devastating
attacks that we've ever seen however at
the same time bonolonov is a something
of an acquired taste in terms of design
i can see why so many people would just
plonk him into last place because he
doesn't look smart and smooth i mean he
is what he is and i guess what he is is
13th place on the opposite end of the
aesthetic scale now we have pretty boy
shalnock in 12th overall not scoring too
differently to bernal enough however and
this surprised me the majority of
placements for shao knock ended up in
the 10th to 14th range and that shocks
me because i'd always thought that
shalnok was a lot more popular than that
maybe sitting at seventh or eighth but i
guess that's just my anecdotal
experience i suppose what might tank
charnock is his less than original
inability and while his design is that's
quite typically appealing it might be a
tad too generic especially in a group
full of all sorts of wacky weirdos
including headweirdo crollo and deputy
head weirdo hisoka it's very difficult
to sit beside those two and have any
chance of standing out still it
intrigues me because number eleven
defeating shanak is kaluto zoldik and if
i had to guess what this ranking would
be out of thin air i probably would have
placed calito in 14th or maybe even last
place but kalito has an almost banalinov
style effect happening here because if
you look at his percentages from fifth
to tenth place it is astoundingly
uniform like you go five percent then
six six six seven seven whereas most
characters have a solid one or two
numbers that the majority of voters pile
into but not carlito which i think shows
that people on average do appreciate
color toe quite a bit although carlito
did receive around 10 percent of all
last place votes
there's also that but this is why we do
ranked choice polls because kalato would
never stand a chance if we just asked
what everyone's number one favorite is
so this is quite revealing of the true
feelings of the hunt hunter fandom it's
a form of fan-based mind-reading not too
dissimilar from the abilities of our
10th place contender parkunoda and this
is where we start to see a noticeable
shift at the top end of voting because
pakunoda received 221 first place
finishes which no it's not much but it's
more than double what kaloto received so
whilst the majority of votes do still
lie in the 10th to 14th range for
pakunoda there is a significant enough
cohort of people placing her in first to
third that just gets her over the line
here and i'd say that the obvious reason
for that is because she's one of the few
troop members to have had a complete
character arc which did result in one of
the more tragic and bittersweet deaths
in hunter hunter pakunoda is memorable
and also memorable because she does have
very pronounced boob things which as
much as i would like to think otherwise
yeah look it probably also played a part
in her support we are taking another big
leap forward now with number nine to
discover one shizuku who not only
finally breaks the two percent barrier
for first place votes but also has the
least amount of last place finishes so
far only 198 people rank shizuku and
15th which is one of the lowest
proportions of any troop member in fact
there are only three members who receive
less last-place votes than shizuku but
shizuku is also well she's kind of right
where she belongs because over 50 people
did place her between 7th to 11th so you
know 9th that sounds like a pretty
lovely middle ground and my general
conclusion here is
what's not to love about shizuku she
might not have the flair to compete with
the true favorites but there's very few
reasons to actively dislike her which i
think is very much reflected in the
numbers making big shockwave style
things now in eighth place we have
overgain this this honestly does floor
me because in my experience uvagine as
one of the best explored members of the
troop tends to hold tremendous respect
and popularity within the fanbase
however with that said the reality of
this is that he got less first place
votes than shizuku did and he also got
around 10 times the amount of last place
votes she did so there's a lot of
disdain food again which i imagine is
because yes he can be a bit of a
heartless murder machine i do indeed
recognize that but the general consensus
of ulvegin sees him landing somewhere
between fifth and eighth however it
really is that lack of top support
combined with the ten percent of people
who put him in last that hold uvagine
back from reaching the top end of that
scale sitting actually kind of
significantly higher now is our seventh
place mr nobunaga very interestingly
only around seven percent of people
ranked nobunaga in either first second
or third which is actually far far less
than overkill but what pushes nobunaga a
fair way ahead of his brother in arms is
the stunning lack of lower scale votes
in total less than 10 of respondents put
nobunaga in 13th 14th or last place
compared to the more than 10 percent who
decided that yes overgain should be dead
last you filthy filthy animal and i
think it's because nobunaga is simply a
solid character cool enough design
swordsman always intriguing and fun and
he has a decent amount of comedic
moments as well thus making nobunaga
kind of like an all-rounder and a very
sturdy representation of the middle tier
of the phantom troop here's where things
become a bit crazy though because for 6
place out of 15 i should note we appear
to have thinx now i really like things
but i don't think i like him quite this
much that is of course fairly irrelevant
though because over 50 percent of all of
you think that things land somewhere
between third and eighth place thinks is
he's actually kind of stupidly popular
but you would never know that from a
poll that only asks for your number one
favorite so good on you thinks my gum
getting into serious business now this
is the upper third and it all kicks off
with machi not too surprising because in
my experience marcia has always been
held as a top-end favorite because she
kind of has it all cool design fun
string based none ability and even some
high emotional stakes in the story being
directly connected to hisoka
interestingly machi's votes are most
heavily weighted in the 5th to 8th place
range however what kicks her into the
top of that is the complete and utter
lack of lower end placements for example
a grand total of 80 people put marchi in
last place then another 130 put her into
14th and only 246 decided that marche
should be even 13th these are incredibly
low numbers and that's actually the
primary reason as to how machi secured
victory over things meanwhile in fourth
place lands illumi zoldick and franime
only fans just quickly yes ilami is
indeed a member of the troop he joined
in the manga shortly after the anime
events concluded and while we could ask
whether it's fair or not to include such
a prolific character on this poll my
hands are kind of tied on the issue he
is a member so i can't really leave him
out and people do have very strong and
consistent feelings towards hillary with
a whopping 17 of all voters slamming him
straight into third place that is the
highest concentration of voters we've
seen so far apart from cortopia's
unfortunate last place and dilemma also
performs exceptionally well in fourth
and fifth positions as well however only
327 people voted to put him into first
which is less than march he thinks and
even shizuku received so in a more
standard pick the favorite poll ilmi
would end up being more like seventh
place but i certainly think that this is
more accurate to award the bronze medal
now i asked feitan porter to step up
into the third place position podium now
feitan is the first character on this
ranking to actually break a 10 point
average which is kind of shocking but i
think it reflects how top heavy
preferences are for our final three now
fake tan certainly is a popular little
rascal with almost 40 voters ranking him
somewhere between first and third but
i'm actually surprised that that wasn't
higher particularly in the first place
sector only
1294 four people elected to hold feitan
as their number one which is
astoundingly higher than anyone else so
far yes but it does pale pretty
radically in comparison to the top two
and with that we announce our second
place finisher being hisoka with a total
of over 4 800 votes in first place and a
staggering 73 percent of all voters
ranking him somewhere between first and
third is this to be expected i mean yes
i guess it is hisoka generally the sword
of paul will always come down to a
battle between crolo and hisoka although
it is very interesting to note that
there are indeed a small portion of
dissenters within the hisoka camp just
over three percent of all people put
hisoka in last place which may not sound
like much but it is actually huge
compared to both feitan and crowler who
received more like half a percent and to
be fair hisoka he can be a controversial
character and i suppose it might even be
surprising that so few people put him in
last place but that of course leads us
into crowning our grand champion who is
of course crolo lucifer however i want
to point out something very very major
here which is that crollo actually
received less first place votes than
hisoka did over 300 or so less so if
this was your standard favorite poll
hisoka would have won and this is why
ranked choice voting is ever so
important it goes whilst there may be
more hardcore hisoka super fans in the
world overall crollo is more generally
appreciated and to put that into some
perspective less than 500 people place
crollo in the 9th to 15th range and out
of 13 000 that's that's just kind of
ridiculous so with that we crown crolo
as the undisputed phantom troop champion
guy but now that we've done this let's
go and do something else something
hunter related probably because there's
always more to learn explore and
experience with this wonderful series so
i look forward to seeing you there